we are taking calls at six one seven
eight three zero four seven five zero
and we will take name and town from our
callers and then hear what it is that
you are talking about we just want to
make sure that that volume level for
them is up name in town where are you
calling from
hi my name is Russell I'm from
California what's going on Russell again
I just want to say I'm a huge fan of
yours by the way great job what you're
doing um you know just after last night
I'm just disappointed and I guess my
question to you is is the large majority
of America really as unintelligent or
alright with you alright with what's
going on I mean is it the large majority
of America really this unintelligent
well so the answer is yes unfortunately
we can't just blame stupid people for
what happened in this election and I
made that really clear on my after
election show where we have to put blame
where blame should be and a lot of that
is on the Democratic National Committee
which pre decided that Hillary Clinton
was the nominee Hillary Clinton a hugely
flawed nominee al biet a very qualified
nominee and we can't just say stupid
people voted Trump now as far as the
Trump electorate yes there are low
information voters that voted for Trump
they think this is some amazing victory
they think we're gonna win again it's
gonna be fantastic it's gonna be
tremendous this or this whole thing
we can't really reach them but the
problem is that there are also other
people who for example said I just want
to shock the system and the way to shock
it is by voting for Donald Trump they
didn't necessarily think Trump was a
smart guy or a great guy there were
other people also there were other
people also Republicans who didn't
particularly like Trump but they voted
for Trump because they didn't want
Hillary Clinton selecting Supreme Court
justices for example so I think it's a
combination of stuff okay yes yeah I see
that
and just a just a quick side question I
guess would be does that also mean that
there's that many bigoted and and I
would have to say racist people in this
country as well there are yeah
the polls showed as you remember Rachel
that there were disproportionately more
Trump supporters than supporters of
other candidates who believe that black
people were inherently lazy because they
were black and these two these types of
things I think the numbers bear that out
don't they that the Trump Trump
coalesced that group yeah yeah he
definitely did he definitely brought out
a really really really large support for
that all right thank you so much for the
call really really appreciated we will
continue to see what is the future of
America after the Select